hi i'm solomon giorgio comedian writer  and gossip queen and just before the  world went on lockdown i had send on a  tweet that changed my life i don't care  about celebrity gossip i said give me  local gossip before i knew it my replies  were full of the juiciest stories i've  ever heard now i'm serving them up on  the juice my brand new podcast from team  coco that's all about low sex gossip if  you love hearing about workplace  romances at denny's moms with secret  lovers and what happened to so-and-so's  high school classmate you're in the  right place join me as i source only the  finest gossip from people like nicole  byer conan o'brien and ira madison iii  and also listeners like you we keep it  low stakes and high petty new episodes  of juice are out every week listen  wherever you get your podcast and have a  juicy day  [Music]